I've only ever seen before a one gram
sample of iridium which I bought myself
for another video and here I've got a
big piece of iridium this weighs 3.8
kilos and iridium is the second densest
metal that exists only osmium is denser
but the difference in density is so
small that you wouldn't really tell the
difference it has one of the highest
melting points as well and I'm really
impressed by this it looks just like an
ordinary piece of metal but it's really
quite heavy I've got this sample because
I'm at the Johnson Matthey noble metal
plant where they actually process this
material they take the sponge which
comes from the mines where they dig up
the rocks and process it and turn it
into metal objects and this piece of rod
is one of the intermediate stages to get
this far one has to process about six or
seven hundred thousand tons of rock a
huge amount of rock nearly a million
tons of rock just to make this why
should people want iridium it's very
useful because it's high melting point
and it's strength because of its high
melting point you can make it into
crucibles this is a very little crucible
but if you want to handle liquids at
high temperature 2,000 degrees
centigrade you have no choice you have
to use an Iridium crucible so here is
quite a small one might make quite a
good vodka glass actually but the real
crucibles that people use say for
growing crystals of silicon and so on
are really much bigger this is a sheet
of iridium for making a crucible you
make the crucible in two pieces you have
a smallest piece here that's the bottom
you cut out a circle and then this piece
is wrapped round to form the sides this
piece of metal which is really very
heavy again will be rolled up and welded
and what's unusual about this she
- metal it's not very thick but it's
absolutely rigid it doesn't bend at all
if you had a piece of steel like this it
would be beginning to feel slightly
bendy you can feel that it has unusual
properties it's not like a metal I felt
before and it's very heavy and this
density makes it very hard and rigid but
you can imagine how much this is worth
because the price of iridium is
approaching 800 pounds and out so these
are very expensive materials and we're
in a metal free zone we are not allowed
to bring in any metal to make sure that
nobody steals in it if you don't have
any metal it makes it easy to screen you
as you go out you have nothing metallic
nothing that's an electrical conductor
so it's easy to screen if you have lots
of bits of metal you might be able to
sneak something through so when I came
here everything went my favorite pen
even my belt from my trousers this is
something I've never seen before this is
where somebody actually chooses the name
of an element so if you look down here I
should incline to call this metal
iridium so this is the first time that
anybody ever wrote down the word iridium
now of course he might have written it
in his notes but this is the first
official record of anybody writing the
word iridium one of the other areas
where you have very high temperatures
are in the tips of spark plugs you know
you put spark plugs into the tops of
cylinders of petrol engines and when the
spark ignites the explosion ignites the
fuel air mixture then you get very high
temperature and you don't want it to
erode away you want the spark plug to
work for thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of miles and you do this by
putting in a tiny Iridium tip these are
the tips of the spark plugs like that
they're really tiny and it's important
to stress
that modern technology depends on making
these tiny tiny components of iridium
and getting them in the right place so
you use the metal you need at the really
important point in the sparkplug
it's must less important what you make
the nut from or the contact at this end
but you've got to get it really right
just there and then you get the maximum
performance I also like these here these
are the grains of iridium that are made
from the sponge that comes from the mine
and the first stage of the processing is
making these rather irregular sized
grains which can then be melted again
and cast into ingots before they make
bars like this earlier on we were shown
a whole tub full of grains of iridium
and I could actually run it through my
hands something I'll never do again
probably but I really just want to pick
this up again make the most of it well
I've got the time so let your periodic
videos Mase yeah for once I can keep
Brady in order iridium is found in very
low concentrations on our planet but
it's found in quite high concentrations
on asteroids and meteorites and a
physicist Luis Alvarez in the 90 early
1980s pointed out that there is a very
thin layer geological layer and the so
called KT boundary in the rocks from 65
million years ago which is rich in
iridium it has a hundred times the
concentration of iridium
and this is believed to come from the
asteroid that hit the earth and killed
all the dinosaurs because it vaporized
and put a layer of iridium around the
world and by tracing this tiny layer of
rock which contains high levels of
iridium the whole theory of how the
dinosaurs disappeared from the world was
developed it wasn't the iridium that
killed the dinosaurs there they were
killed by the explosion but it was the
iridium that left the signature that let
us understand what had happened
you wouldn't write English quite like
that nowadays
this metal iridium here is the name
iridium and here he says from the
striking variety of colors which it
gives well dissolving in and I can't
read the name of the acid it could be
muriatic acid